hello I'm Greg Sadler and this is number
seven in a new series of videos shot
specifically for people who are carrying
out self-directed study in philosophy
whether they're lifelong learners or
students enrolled somewhere that want to
supplement the curriculum that they're
getting and this one focuses on a rather
broad spectrum I'm not even sure you can
call it a philosophical school as such
and that is early Christian philosophy
so we're talking about thinkers who
identify as philosophers in a very broad
sense all the way up to the time say of
Augustine of Hippo I'll do a separate
video about studying his works later on
so in this video I'm going to give you
some of the fruits of my experience in
researching in this area and sometimes
teaching a few of these thinkers and
texts and doing some writing on them as
well and why it might be useful for you
to study these people that you probably
haven't actually heard of most likely
and what the the approaches that you
might want to take would be now just to
get an idea of who we're talking about
when we're bringing up Christian
philosophers particularly early
Christian philosophers we're talking
about people like Justin Martyr like
clement of alexandria there's an entire
Alexandrian school that also includes
origin and a number of his students and
those inspired by him locked on Sia's
Gregory nice also probably Gregory of
Nazneen Gregory thought motor guess
you'll notice there's a lot of Gregory's
in the history of Christian thought of
Audrey is Pontius John Cassian we might
even include people who were in some
respect ante philosophical but used
some of the techniques and ideas of
philosophy to attack other other people
or to defend the faith like Tertullian
or taught ian in his address to the to
the greeks so if you haven't heard of
these people that's a okay I'm gonna
talk about who they were and why you
might want to check them out and we're
going to go through a number of
different things that hopefully will
give you some some impetus and some
groundwork for studying early Christian
philosophers
early on in every one of these videos I
address a very important question a
totally legitimate question why should I
study this stuff what what am I going to
get out of reading 2nd 3rd 4th 5th
century philosophers who might not even
really qualify as philosophers in the
modern sense who were definitely
influenced by Christianity and sometimes
engaged in apologetics people I've never
heard of why should I study this stuff
and one of the answers that I'll come
back to in the end is you know if you
actually do dig into them you're gonna
find them incredibly interesting and
eye-opening but let's put that off for a
second why else should you study these
thinkers so if you're interested in the
certain we might call it classic set of
problems that comprise philosophy and
you like to get a broad spectrum of
approaches to it so what are we talking
about here problems like what is the
nature of the universe is it created it
doesn't have an origin in time you know
what is time and space these
cosmological questions obviously
questions about you know anything
dealing with religion but also questions
dealing with what we can call the
Anthropology of the human person you
know what is a human being and do we
have free will or not what is the nature
of moral goodness and evil how how
should society be organized these are
all classic philosophical questions we
can add to them questions of
epistemology what is knowledge how do I
know things what is truth how can I be
sure about anything and we can even
think about questions dealing with
philosophy and its own history and
relations between philosophy and other
important aspects of culture or other
disciplines all of these are discussed
in
way or another by figures within this
long tradition of early Christian
philosophy that feeds in later on to the
figures that were a little bit more
experienced in in talking about and in
in researching and reading so let me
jump into that next as another reason
why you might want to read save Justin
Martyr or locked-on seus or origin or
Clement of Alexandria so in the early
Christian period in in terms of
philosophy which usually for most
textbooks ends up beginning with
Augustine which is actually a little bit
late right and then talks about say
boëthius and goes into well there's the
dark ages but at least there's you know
gonna Sarah Gina and maybe they'll talk
about alcoa in the monk and the Carolyn
Ginny and Renaissance and then we get to
these luminaries like Anselm and Abelard
and perhaps some of the other monastic
writers and then we get to of course
Thomas Aquinas and Bonaventure and now
we're in the high middle ages
well these early Christian writers had
an influence on those later Christian
writers not not surprisingly because
they were part of culture and in the
monasteries the monks were not only
copying out you know Seneca and Cicero
and Ovid and all these other pagan
authors they were also copying for
example John Cassian now you know
Benedict of Nursia
suggests in his rule for his monks that
they ought to read John Cassian so of
course you need copies of John Cassian
and casseon is referring back to other
people and using concepts coming from
other people so it's it's kind of
helpful if you want to understand all
these interesting references in later
thinkers to know who these people are
and and you know they as they were
rediscovered by later
modern philosophy
suffers some some of them will get
referenced as well and if you don't know
the reference is well you can't really
understand what those discussions are
bearing upon their their part of the
culture of Late Antiquity
and that's another reason why it's worth
knowing them there's a lot of ways in
which we present ancient philosophy as
if it's you know these five big schools
you know the plate mists later on
including the neoplatonist the
Aristotelian 's the Stoics the sceptics
the Epicureans and then there's a few
minor other things and there's a few
Jewish thinkers on the side like Hillel
van Alexandria and then there's there's
all these Christians that come a bit
later but they're doing a Christian
thing and it's their own stick and we
create this totally artificial
separation between Christian
intellectual culture and pagan
intellectual culture that is like I said
totally artificial because they
permeated each other at the time that
they're developing and they're engaging
each other quite a bit
it just so happens that that the
Christians essentially won the the field
but they they still kept you know
engaging with the pagan culture that
that they knew and in the early you know
first 300 400 years it was not a
foregone conclusion as a matter of fact
within Christianity they were not just
you know struggling intellectually with
and sometimes for and against the pagans
they were also dealing with all sorts of
non Orthodox Christian views as well so
you know we find one of the interesting
philosophical documents is actually a
disputation with money you know the head
of the Manicheans that ended up becoming
a for a short time a major religious
movement within the Roman Empire and far
outside of it as well so by studying
these thinkers you get to fill in a lot
of important gaps and it's you can do
this whether you're a
believer or whatever doubt denomination
you might belong to or whether you're
you know as secularist as you can
possibly get if you have an appreciation
for the life of the mind and you are
relatively free from bigotry you will
actually get a lot out of studying these
people so that leads me back to the the
question of interest with every
philosophical figure one of the correct
answers to well why should I study this
person or this group of people is
because when you lend yourself to their
works and ideas and spend the time to
try to think you know their perspectives
out you will find that there are things
to them that are intrinsically and
inherently interesting and worthwhile of
study even if you don't agree with it
and you know you don't have to agree
with with people in philosophy to get a
lot out of them I I disagree with Hume
and Kant and Descartes and I love
reading them and studying them and
teaching them so if you're that kind of
person then studying these these early
you know essentially second to fifth
century Christian philosophers will
indeed be something valuable for you
before we get into the deeper and
perhaps even more interesting questions
having to do with methodology and
assumptions and how not to trip yourself
up and what to keep in mind and context
we do have to talk about some practical
questions that have to do with books
themselves now there's a number of
different thinkers that I've already
mentioned ranging from you know Justin
Martyr all the way to John Cassian and
you might say to some where am I going
to get these books what translation
should I be looking at and is there any
good secondary literature out there
about this and about the idea of
Christian philosophy in general so
there's a lot to talk about there first
off in the video description if you
scroll down you click the show more you
will see a listing of different thinkers
who are worth checking out this is not a
comprehensive list but you know there
were there people who you should take a
look at now which translations that's an
interesting question when it comes to
this I my view is whatever translations
you can get your hands on because these
are not thinkers who people are paying
an awful lot of attention to and
continually retranslated the way they do
with say Plato or Aristotle or even
these days the Stoics they're a bit more
of a backwater so you got to use the
translations you can find many of their
works
fortunately can be found online but you
can also purchase them one of the things
that I have that I actually am quite
happy about that I bought there are
these these books and these translations
are quite old and sometimes a little bit
tendentious but there's these anti
Nicean and posts I see and fathers
series and it's got a lot of these these
you know Christian philosophers in
they're not necessarily all of their
works and those are those are kind of
nice to have I managed to pick them up
the entire set for
or 200 bucks when normally a cost I
think about 1,300 a lot of libraries
have those and you can also find many of
these works in other places if you can
read Greek or Latin another major source
to go to that these translations were
using as their source texts is the mean
patre logia mean was the name of a monk
and the Patra logia the you know logo
the logo of the father's the potters
there's a patro logia latina and a Patra
logia graeca those are online as well I
hope still it's been a while since I
looked at it and you never know if sites
are gonna be taken down but that can be
fun to dig around in that takes a little
bit of research skills to do now when it
comes to secondary literature there
there are a few relatively new studies
out in the the 2000 teens that would be
worth checking out because they deal
with this thematically one is George
Karl Karim analysis the philosophy of
early Christianity that's worth taking a
look at Anthony Meredith is Christian
philosophy in the early church not bad
as well I have a very short discussion
of the topic in my reason fulfilled by
revelation my 2011 work but that's
mostly focused about on the 1930s debate
about Christian philosophy so I don't
hit on it too much but I do want to
mention one person who was heavily
involved in that debate Etienne Jill
stone this is actually one of the books
that he wrote during the debate this is
his Gifford lectures the spirit of
medieval philosophy this really only
talks about the early Christian
philosophers thematically in the first
two chapters but there's some good notes
in here he's more interested in talking
about the Middle Ages and in dealing
with things the matically so it'll come
up from time to time but he also has
this really great and I have the French
you know the
English translation is just philosophy
of the Middle Ages I have the French
copy of it that felis 5000 menage days
origin podcast ich I the fan do
Cathy I'm Zack so you know from the firm
it's patristic origins and you know he
really means it so the first uh you know
first hundred and thirty pages or so is
is devoted to early Christian thinkers
so that's quite good as well I will
mention that cobblestone does have a
chapter in his medieval philosophy
volume about these thinkers it's about
thirty pages or so it's just called the
patristic period and it's not not
particularly good but it at least tells
you who's who and where they fit in a
couple other works that are worth
bringing up so this is a fairly recent
one 2016 1 true life this is about the
Stoics and early Christians it it it
really only touches on one thinker who
were interested in and that's Justin
Martyr one of the first Christian
philosophers but it's worth checking out
Richard Saurabh geez emotion and peace
of mind from stoic agitation of
Christian temptation is is quite good as
a study in general and it does have some
some good final chapters that that
discuss these things chapters 22 through
25 are are well I mean already it's
getting into Augustine in 24 but you you
you can get quite a bit of the moral
philosophy of moral psychology from
there and then I another work that I
would it doesn't talk about Christian
philosophy very much but I would
recommend for getting
idea about the development of Christian
moral conceptions is Wayne Meeks the
origins of Christian morality in the
first two centuries pretty good you know
it was kind of groundbreaking in its
time we're talking about the 90s I think
that's quite a quite a lot of it you
know holds up pretty well so you know
those are some of the places that you
might go but there's really no
substitute for actually reading the
thinkers themselves and delving into
these texts so that's what we need to
talk about next
so another practice
question having to do with books is
right where do I start
who should I read what text ought I be
focusing on and I want to put one worry
aside right from the beginning there's
no right way to start with us and
there's no like prescribed order that
you have to read these texts in you're
not going to screw up your education by
beginning with the wrong person or
missing a text or something like that I
personally would say that a natural
place to begin is by looking at Justin
martyrs first and second apology because
he's one of the earliest Christian
self-identified philosophers and you
know if you know your ancient philosophy
you'll recognize the other schools that
he's talking about so you've got at
least some idea about where he's saying
Christianity fits in and adds something
to the picture you've got some basis to
to start with and then another good work
that I would say maybe is the next one
to read would be locked on seus and you
know his major work is the divine
Institute's but I wouldn't say start
with that I would say start with this
shorter work that's really quite
interesting on the wrath or on the anger
of God because again he's doing the same
thing that Justin Martyr is he's arguing
for a Christian position and he's he's
positioning it in relation to these
other ancient philosophies schools in
this case the Aristotelian Xand Stoics
and play tennis and Epicureans and and
he knows their positions quite well and
then he's saying create the Christian
idea or Christian approach is gonna
incorporate what's right in these and
then go beyond them by introducing new
new sources and new insights and you
know things along those lines and he has
a very interesting position on whether
gets angry or not a one that I think is
is a bit counterintuitive for many
present-day Christians so that might be
another reason why why it's worth
checking it out
he's also an early thinker as well and
then clement of alexandria definitely
somebody that you want to read i would
say read his straw mata he has some
really interesting insights about the
nature of the human person you know he
says that one way that we're made in the
image of god is by being musical i mean
that's that's a mind-blowing idea isn't
it and he spells it out there he also
talks about ancient greek philosophy as
being a preparation for the gospel for
the greeks the way that the hebrew
scriptures were for the for the jewish
people who would later become christians
right at the convert so that's a really
interesting idea as well i i think that
you get you read those three and then
maybe add to it origins against cal sis
because Origen major early theologian of
the Alexandrian school he is writing
against this pagan philosopher kelsa s--
who is criticizing Christianity so
origin is using Christian ideas but also
using philosophical reasoning and and
all sorts of you know other you know
ideas coming from pagan philosophy to
argue for the reasonableness of
Christianity and then there's there's a
few others that are worth checking out
tatiane has a really interesting
argument or exhortation against the
Greeks in which he's trying to argue
again for for the superiority of
Christianity against ancient Greek
philosophy but the the other two
thinkers that I think you should
probably check out early on are - who do
a lot with what we call moral psychology
and ethics and also are very interest in
the issue of free will -
one of them is of Agrius of Pontic us
and he wrote a lot of books so I would
say if you have to pick one his
practicals would be would be good and
then there's John Cassian who I
mentioned already and I would he's got
to swell these got three books but
there's two that are particularly
germane the the Institute's and then the
conference's the conference's are his
accounts of conferences with monastic
fathers out in the desert
I would actually leave that for later I
would read the Institute's where where
he's talking about how to set up a
monastery and what monastic life ought
to look like and the bulk of it is
discussing something that of Agrius also
discusses the eight capital vices which
become later the seven deadly sins and
the insights that cassian is displaying
while assimilating ideas from monastic
life and from ancient philosophy and
Christian Scripture and you know sort of
working them all through our pretty
brilliance he really adds a lot so I
mean that's also a good companion piece
to locked-on see is's on the on the
anger of god which talks a lot about
human anger so those are some good
starting points and they'll give you a
nice flavor for what these thinkers are
interested in what they're talking about
what kind of approaches they take there
is a good bit of variety among those I
think I mentioned six different thinkers
maybe seven with Tatia in there right so
we got Justin lactantius origin of
Agrius kassian Clement and tatiane that
seven yeah so between those seven guys I
think you're getting a pretty good
representative sample and then you can
decide if you want to go on further and
you'll have a good grounding as well you
have a good lay of the land you might
say with with reading those those seven
now as you're approaching these works
there are a number of things that you
want to keep in mind having to do with
their their culture and historical
context and the you might say grand
picture preoccupations and motives of
doing that kind of thinking and work and
the backgrounds of these people as well
so to begin with one thing that you
really want to keep in mind is that some
of these Christian authors didn't start
out Christian they actually started out
you know being interested in philosophy
first and then found themselves
launching into Christianity and they
didn't leave the philosophy totally
behind I didn't bring up somebody like
Jerome who wavered between you know the
Bible and Cicero and eventually said I
can't read Cicero anymore because I'm
much more attracted to the people who
are less about you know there's the
faith and philosophy and put philosophy
over here I like that I like the guys
who are saying well Christianity brings
a new kind of philosophy into the world
and we have to take what's good from the
older philosophies and then reject the
bad stuff I think that's much more of an
interesting project and so you know
Justin Martyr for example is a convert
right so he actually talks about that in
his apologies and as another dialogue to
trifle right so that's important and and
you've got to also place yourself in the
frame of mind where like many of the
other ancient philosophies and even
other things that were not considered
you know philosophy by us but were
adjunct to philosophy you know like
Madison or literature history these were
understood as a way of life and
Christianity
was not just a new way of life where you
turn your brain off
it was taking well I was for some people
right just just faith no reason then
your church Tertullian what does Athens
have to do with Jerusalem most of these
early Christian philosophers didn't take
that approach
like I said clement of alexandria saw
greek philosophy is a preparation for
the gospel they are trying to take oh
you know what what's good in this very
broad ancient culture that many of them
were incredibly steeped in and and well
trained in some of them were rhetorician
some of them were philosophers some of
them were other professions and then
they've got scripture and it's good to
keep in mind that our notion of the
Bible you know as a book is incredibly
anachronistic there was never a book it
was table which means the books right if
you actually crack open a Bible and you
start reading around you will be if you
haven't been already incredibly
impressed by just what a diversity of
genres you're talking about you've got
these you know we read you know numbers
or Leviticus and you're like holy crap
that's a lot of laws a lot of
Commandments there and then read judges
you're like whoa this is like adventure
stories you know crazy epic stuff about
you know Samson and and beating up the
Philistines and then read the wisdom
literature and the wisdom literature
itself isn't just like proverbs and
Ecclesiastes and job which are
incredibly philosophical it also
includes things like the song of songs
which reads like an erotic letter to
somebody you're like what exactly is
going on here and then you've got these
interesting narrative works like Ruth
you've got all these prophets doing
saying interesting things some of which
you're like man I don't understand any
of these references and it doesn't
really seem to mean that much and then
others you like you read Amos and you're
like whoa that's stuff about injustice
and oppressing the poor that is as
applicable today
as it was back then this is amazing
stuff so these these early thinkers were
being confronted with that and they're
trying to you know sort of bring
together a new synthesis that would
would you know manage to to take the
insights coming from Scripture including
all the stuff having to do with this
this Jesus fellow who shows up and
starts teaching and and then people
eventually are saying this guy's got and
he's teaching not an extremely
straightforward way well when he is
quite straightforward it's really tough
stuff to hear right teaches through
these parables and signs and people well
what does that mean and what's going on
with this so these are things that
people are puzzling out and there wasn't
a rigid distinction as it turns out
later on between like okay so here on
this side is philosophy and the life of
reason here on this side is theology and
the life of blind faith that's a
nonsense idea that comes from later
crappy writers from the Enlightenment we
had axes to grind there there always
will be and there always have been some
people who do treat things that way even
in the high middle ages we have Peter
Damien saying even grammar is a tool of
the devil right but they're the
exception rather than the rule if you
look at these early Christian thinkers
they were thinkers they were attempting
to think out the world in new
circumstances within an ever-changing
culture that had already now hundreds of
years behind it and they're trying to
make make a new way of life a rational
coherent way of life out of it and so
they're doing philosophy philosophy back
then essentially meant a not just
intellectual exercise it meant a way of
committing yourself and living things
out and Christianity comes to be viewed
as one more philosophy among others as a
matter of fact it wants monasticism
real going concern so we're talking
about sort of the end of this era moving
into the early Middle Ages what the
monks were doing was often called
Christian philosophy philosophy as a way
of life so that's one thing that's going
on another thing that that you could say
is is the key part of their their
motivations is engaging in polemics
there is a lot of shared cultural space
people are jockeying for position in it
there there are current you know pagan
philosophers out there claiming that
this new religious point of view is
actually irrational and doesn't make
sense or is bad for the Empire which was
one of callouses claims and it's
actually one of the things motivating
Justin Martyr to write his apologies
saying that Christianity is actually
good for the Empire in some ways because
the Christians are being persecuted so
there's all of that going on all of this
engagements and then there's also what
we can call intra Christian struggles
and rivalries they're trying to clarify
what their beliefs actually are and so
they get into arguments with it some of
them will actually fall into what are
considered heresies we'll talk about
that word in just a minute
like for example Tara tolian he is a
extreme rigorous he argues against these
other positions eventually he becomes a
montanus now a heresy nowadays we look
at this word heresy and we're like oh
yeah that's something Christians use or
religious people use to oppress other
people hi racists originally means
choice and it means a choice of a
particular way of life so you know it
was used to describe philosophical
schools it's also used to describe
religious communities like that of the
Manicheans or that of the montanus or
that of the Aryans all of these are high
racists choices commitments ways of
living and a good part of early
Christian thought the Orthodox thought
that we're talking about here is aimed
at combating what they view as erroneous
understandings of not just Christianity
but the things that it bears upon like
the notion of whether we have free will
or not or whether the Incarnation
matters or doesn't matter whether you
know what kind of what does God like is
God finite infinite all of these sorts
of things are issues that they're
hashing out and they're not just doing
it in theological councils they're doing
it in philosophical works as well like
one of the key things that I really find
fascinating about this time period is
they are they are trying to hash out the
notion of free will and what it means so
these are all background assumptions
that you want to keep in mind as you're
reading these these thinkers you should
assume that they probably know more
about ancient philosophy then than you
likely do as a reader and that they had
access to texts that we no longer have
text from the Epicureans or the Stoics
or the skeptics or even lost works by
other Aristotelian zorp lateness the
last thing I want to say about this is
that there's a there's a prevalent
misinterpretation that we'll will say
you know early Christian thought is all
basically neoplatonist they just took
Plato and they got his thoughts through
these you know watered-down glosses on
him and then they just assimilated it
because they they like Plato better than
the other thinkers again when you go
back to the text and you read it you see
that that is that is just not the case
at all they often did say well Plato is
closest to what we're doing but they
also appropriate things from the Stoics
they took on some things occasionally
from the Aristotelian tradition
they're pretty conversant with the
history of philosophy this notion that
they were just like you know sort of you
know
grafting Christianity on the Platonic
philosophy pure nonsense they they did
in fact engage with a lot of the middle
and and and neoplatonism of the time
which itself was incredibly eclectic so
it's it's you know you have to have sort
of a more realistic view on what's going
on and in order to do that you've got to
go to the texts there's no way around
that and you've got to approach them
with fairly unblinking eyes so you don't
want to rely too much on somebody else's
history of ideas because that will give
you preconceptions that will make it
harder for you to appreciate what's
actually in front of you
I also think it's important to give a
bit of advice that stems from the let's
call it genres or contexts of these
works philosophy is an interesting field
in that there this despite the the
attempts of some people to try to say
philosophy has to be done in this format
all you got to do is like read a little
bit in the history of philosophy to
realize that that's complete nonsense
anybody who's trying to sell you the
idea that philosophy has to be done in
the in the form of the treatise or the
dialogue or the academic article is
either stupid or you know intellectually
lazy or trying to sell you something or
puffed up with pride or whatever there's
something wrong and going on there and
so you know when it comes to these sorts
of texts you see them doing some of the
same things that we see other ancient
philosophers doing writing dialogues for
example but also writing longer treaty
sees that are arranged in books a book
would be a scroll and then there'd be
chapters within the book but they can be
incredibly diverse in their approaches
to things so you'll find you'll find
actual dialogues where people are
talking with each other sometimes there
are more literary sometimes less so I
did mention that that you know account
of the argument between a philosopher I
want to say it's FN aghoris and and
monney as an interesting example of a
kind of dialogue it's supposed to be
like an actual transcript of a debate
apologies are another thing you know
we've got this term apologetics and
nowadays it's come to mean something
like starting from the standpoint of
faith and just trying to find arguments
for it to convince people but an apology
originally was a defense speech Socrates
apology right is Socrates defending
himself and Justin martyrs apologies are
his attempt to defend the Christians
against Roman officials who
really understand what the Christians
believe and stand for so he's trying to
explain to them why the Christians are
not an actual threat to the Roman Empire
and don't deserve persecution there are
a number of other interesting formats
the one thing that I think you want to
keep in mind is you're looking at this
stuff
not so much to try to appreciate the
prose itself or the format there is one
exception to this that I'll mention well
there's two exceptions to this that I'll
mention in just a minute you're you're
looking at it for the content you're
looking at it for what they're actually
saying so don't allow these genre or the
style to lead you off track if you think
that there's too many scripture quotes
sprinkled in there don't worry about
those the first read don't worry about
that just go on to the philosophical
content the real meat now I mentioned
that there are a few exceptions and I
was only going to talk about two that
are that are particularly noteworthy in
pre Augustinian writing because
Augustine himself is an amazing writer
one would be lactantius
locked on see is is is is a wonderful
writer in Latin well worth reading and
studying for his own sake but also for
the sake of the ideas and then there's
of course John Chrysostom if you know
what Chrysostom means it means golden
mouth the guy who could really talk well
and so you know you can imagine the
stuff that he says this is quite quite
good stylistically so you know reading
them can be quite nice I I really
enjoyed clement of alexandria you know
John Cassian is doing another sort of
thing he's got those conferences as I
mentioned with with the various Abbott's
and monks and then he's got the
Institute's where he's laying out sort
of a blueprint for what a monastery
ought to look like and how they had a
structure their days and then what are
the capital vices that cause us all
these troubles so
you know the long and short of it is for
you you just look at the format or the
genre of the work and try not to allow
your your preconceptions about what a
philosophical work ought to look like
keep you from getting into it and you
know when there's good style appreciate
that
I do want to once again give a few
cautions about what not to allow
yourself to get drawn into or to worried
about because it'll get in the way of
reading and appreciating and
understanding the works you can
certainly you know come back to them and
bring all these preoccupations if you
want to but I think on a first read
it'll be helpful for you to suspend or
bracket or put them aside so the first
one is you know is this stuff philosophy
at all because it doesn't fit a
definition of philosophy that we you
know that you're used to so if you for
example came up in a a sort of
philosophical tradition where you were
told that having any sort of faith
commitments nullified it as philosophy
you you you're really gonna have to put
that aside or you can't read this stuff
effectively because it you know
philosophy if we think about
philosophies history it's
extraordinarily broad there is no
consensus agreement on exactly what
counts as philosophy what doesn't count
as philosophy and the very notion of
drawing a dividing line between
philosophy and theology or philosophy
and faith or philosophy and religion
that is a later concept that comes about
in the Middle Ages and it's essentially
a theological position itself or if it's
a philosophical position it's a pretty
weird one it's become quite popular as
as you know philosophy became more and
more secularized in the modern period
but it's you know it really represents a
set of dogmatic assumptions that do need
to be called into question when we look
at the broad history of philosophy and
what's counted as philosophy because if
you think that having any sort of
religious commitments precludes you from
doing philosophy then Aristotle isn't
philosophy nor is Cicero nor
are any of the Stoics nor does Plato see
nor is Descartes nor you know you have
to leave so much aside you have to throw
out basically all the babies with the
bathwater and you're just left with a
crappy bathtub you know so so that's
that's one big one right there you also
probably don't need to know in and out
you know every one of the philosophical
schools or thinkers that these people
are engaging with so you you don't have
to track everything down as I've said so
many other times with with other
traditions and thinkers expect to read
and reread and reread and get more and
more out of it each time so you can
slowly build up the network of the
interconnection what we call
intertextual intertextuality where our
texts are referring to other texts and
philosophers other philosophers so that
that is another key issue the other
thing to keep in mind too is I think a
lot of people they worry when they're
reading religious thinkers well what if
I don't I don't believe you know or what
if I'm actually like a committed atheist
or what if I'm what if I belong to a
different religion is this going to pose
a problem for me and some people I think
are actually afraid that they might get
converted that could happen through
reading these people right but more
often it's a matter of like coming to
them already can on guard and suspicious
and not wanting to see where the
thoughts go and being a little bit too
prone to say aha
that's just their religious commitment
there well I'm not saying you can't do
that that you know it's you're free to
do whatever you want but if you approach
things with that sort of mentality you
won't get out of it what what other
people do you don't have to believe in
any of this stuff in order to
recognize the interesting approaches and
value of these texts and thinkers I mean
any more than you have to like buy into
dualism to appreciate the cart or you
know accept Kant's you know distinction
between the phenomenal and the the
nominal in order to appreciate Kant and
I and I think you know it's interesting
there's there's people who are more
willing to give a non-religious
philosopher the benefit of the doubt to
see where they're going then they are
with religious philosophers like I said
you you could get converted by this but
it's probably you know rather rare that
that happens and if it were to happen it
would be because of some inherent
rationality of the ideas because all of
these people are indeed philosophers
they are devoted to the life of the mind
they think that God gave human beings
rationality for us to use it they're not
bible thumpers just try to convert
anybody they they want what drew them
into Christianity and Christian
philosophy in particular they want a
fully developed life of the mind so so
when you're approaching these texts you
want to approach them with a kind of
spirit of openness doesn't mean that you
have to accept everything but you want
to try to understand that's the key
thing understanding not agreement not
even necessarily appreciation but
understanding is is really critical
so I do have a few final words and final
thoughts to impart to you and one of
them is I myself personally really do
enjoy reading a lot of these thinkers
some more than others
admittedly and seeing how developed the
the conceptions they had were and how
interconnected their work was with
ancient philosophy and ancient culture
as a whole I always find that just
fascinating and perhaps you will as well
it'll fill in gaps it'll show you a very
interesting picture of humanity that
they were probably in many respects at
least on an intellectual level as smart
in the second century to the 5th century
as we are today and just as curious
about fundamental questions they they of
course didn't have the entire basis that
we have to work with but you know they
they really did have quite a lot to draw
upon and I think that if you if you do
lend yourself to these thinkers and
texts in the right frame of mind you
will find it quite rewarding to study
them and as I pointed out earlier a lot
of sort of blind spots or gaps will that
you didn't even realize were there in
the history of ideas will get filled in
the last thing I'll say too is there's
there's many more Christian thinkers
that can qualify as philosophers or who
are engaging with philosophy and some
some explicit way often using the term
philosophy then I've discussed here so
this is just sort of scratching the
surface but I'm hoping that the people
that I've talked about you know I think
they're acknowledged as being pretty
central and being the the
representatives of Christian philosophy
early Christian philosophy so you know I
I'm I'm not steering you wrong with that
but there's there's a lot more if you're
going to do self directed study in this
that that you would want to explore more
obscure figures going deeper into some
of them and seeing the connections
between them so that's what I'll leave
with the great task ahead of you if you
take this challenge on if not you know
there's plenty of other thinkers to
study as well
you